even a good man would have a hard time
being in Tiger Woods positions having a
position having a Bus full of models
waiting for him that are trying to [ __ ]
him every single day it's like even a
good like my dad I'll give you he's top
one percent doesn't cheat but my dad
doesn't have social media and he doesn't
have beautiful models waiting for him
every day after work I think that would
be hard for even a good man to say no to
you like even my dad if he was in a
position where beautiful women are
trying to do that every single day
that's hard that's really hard for a guy
get approached as well in fact true true
true but it's not usually it's not
usually by men you want it would I would
also argue I would also argue that it
would be hard for a woman to stay
faithful if every day she was approached
by high value men that's true so but
yeah like you've been in that position
it's yeah it's if every day you're
getting messages from like the top men
and Society
I I think that's hard for women to turn
down we're hypergamous so it's not
really about the quantity of men that
approach you it's the quality just
morally I think everybody knows that
cheating is wrong you know like Tay even
said it himself when a woman cheats on a
man the pain that he feels so they know
it's wrong innately but they think that
they have that path to do it because I'm
a man I'm a high value man and it's like
do you know that pain that you felt she
feels that it's yeah no I and I I agree
with you I've I've been cheated on it
was really hard but but at the end of
the day it's just not the same because
like at the end of the day like I could
get past it because I was like you know
what it was just a random it wasn't like
he wasn't in love with her but like the
way we would feel if a man was in love
with someone else that's how men feel
about us cheating on them sexually like
there's just uh do you think it's
because there's just like uh how do I
want to say this do you think it's
because men men are weaker in that
department to where it's like oh you
can't even I can't believe you had sex
with guys before you even met me because
that's my [ __ ] you know what I mean
like I almost feel like it's because
there's such a gap in where women really
are and where men are emotionally and
mentally I no I just think it's like men
and we can't undo biology right so like
we can't undo the thousands of years of
biology and how did you pass on your
genes to the Next Generation for women
it was getting the best man that they
possibly could the strongest tallest
biggest highest status because then your
kid would survive that meant he could
protect you he could pass on resources
to you and your kid would be strong and
would be able to protect itself for like
vice versa for men it was I don't want
to pass on resources to a kid that's not
mine so it was I can't have a
promiscuous woman because the kid might
not be mine my jeans might not even get
yeah my genes might not get passed down
so even though like we're in 2022 and we
have like different things that off set
this stuff you can't undo our biology
but I also think it's accountability I
think like
Britney was saying take you're literally
like the male version of me and you're
praised and I'm shamed I think it's
because we are not holding these men
accountable like you would say you
basically called Break me a home before
you met her that is so unfair and I
think if we started to say no Brittany
Not Just Brittany in that situation not
when you are or anything not in that
situation say taste a hoe Britain is a
hoe actually hold each other accountant
and it's just it's just but here's
here's the thing like on the other side
on the other side when you were away
when was the first time you got messaged
by someone with a blue check mark or
like any attention probably when I was
like 20 21 okay 2021 she got the world
at her fingertips like just just by
being beautiful right she can get
messaged from like the top men in
society it's not the same for man when a
man's 20 21 no woman's checking for him
maybe maybe a very select few but even
even if they're very good looking like
they're not they're not getting [ __ ]
from Rich girls
no but what I'm what I'm saying is the
men so we're all getting those women
like actually saying that it's because
it's not right at the end of the
cheating is wrong men or women biology
or no it's wrong and I think if we
actually start to say you know what this
man has got three baby mamas you're
[ __ ] ridiculous and here's the thing
but the thing is it's such okay it's
such a who who's at fault when most 80
of women 90 of women are sexually active
but only roughly five to ten percent of
guys can do what you're saying so it's
the women are more promiscuous than the
man it's like the problem you're talking
about is so miniscule it's so small like
maybe 20 of men can't say women are more
promiscuous
women women have more sexual partners
now what are you doing I'm coming for
you today now I'm your Auntie Jenny
trust me
way too much I did not accept this
respect this is why men will cheat
because somebody's talking to you and
you're still cutting them off for no
reason please continue so it doesn't
even need to be high value but do you
know what I'm saying so I'm saying like
Okay they're predicting that 45 of women
will be single and childless that's that
so much so that the big banks are
predicting this these women that are
going to be single and childless and are
on the path to that it's not like
they're not sexually active they're
probably sleeping with someone there's
not a plethora of virgins around that
are women but there is one in three men
under 30 or virgins
so who who's more promiscuous if the
women aren't virgins the body counts are
getting higher the the and where on the
other hand men it's a very small
percentage that can actually get sex and
father a bunch of kids so that's why I
say like I know Tate tries he's like
don't make it he said she said but but
just by and large it's more on the women
because one we're in control of sex we
pick who we sleep with and we're more
sexually active than them in a sense I
agree because on average yes you're
right
um women are having sex a lot more
however when we're talking about
promiscuity men have three times more
sexual partners than women so when men
have I think it's like 24 and
um
I made sure because I thought my recent
people coming back I was like okay I
need to I need to know so if if that's
true again it goes back to The Prado
principle right so let's say the average
number is higher for for men typically
it's because the top five twenty percent
even we'll even say thirty percent of
men let's give them 30. like they they
sleep with 50 60 100 150 girls but one
out of three are virgins or haven't had
sex in the past year historically
historically exactly that's why I agree
with that but that's why I'm saying like
by and large women are sleeping with a
very small percentage of men but like
how many percentage are ruining it for
the other men they keep sleeping with so
many women they're ruining it for them
okay so actually it's that part you
could argue that but you could also say
it's more on the women because we're in
control of sex most men like if we went
to a biological level their biology is
to sleep with whoever they can
right they buy like most men if you get
if you get if you get if you get right
but but for the men right where we have
to be more selective and sacred with who
we give it to right like we we value sex
more like emotionally than men do
they'll just and like most men you get
butt naked in front of them
what they're they're not too and so it's
like you're telling that small
percentage of men like oh don't don't do
that okay fine but at the end of the day
I think it's more on women because
there's more sexually promiscuous women
than there are sexually promiscuous men
and it's men's mating strategy to do
that that's their biology where it's not
an armed biology to be promiscuous but
we're the ones doing it but we have this
like feminism empowerment you can do
whatever you want and still be fat where
it's like I feel like as as women if if
like you should come back and say you
know what wait for someone that loves
you you know wait for so wait for this
wait for that
um that's that's just my opinion on it I
just think it's more on the women
because there's more of us doing it than
the men
yeah kinda I mean I don't promote
promiscuity but I just think that
there's just a double standards where
like men are just seen as it is what it
is it's just biological you should like
sex more but women enjoy sex they do
like it's okay would you know what the
biggest problem I would say is really
really really really and truly is the
fact that all of a sudden from one for
one reason or the other everybody wants
to talk about who they are having sex
with and who they take to bed to the
point that you disclosing your sexual
orientation is something that is even
important at the end of the day listen
you may know that I'm not a virgin
because I like I told you I was in a
relationship for fire you're not
whatever
listen whatever I do or don't do is not
for people to know right it's not for
people to want to discuss it's not for
people unless I'm gonna show you my body
my naked body I don't need to talk to
you about whatever I do in bed with
someone else and yeah I think that's one
of the problems that also people are
having you know they're going to be like
listen as a woman you can have sex fine
what matters mostly first and foremost
is how you handle yourself how selective
you may be at the end of the day they
look for Purity to a certain extent but
if you're not a virgin don't worry my
sister hide yourself well don't be there
expecting men to accept women to to just
be sexually open and move in certain
ways that are mad and not not get the
repercussion that is why when I dress
myself I am a beautiful woman with a
good body I am and I know and I don't
need anybody else to tell me I got a
mirror but guess what when I walk around
I dress in a certain way why because I
want to display myself in a way that
brings back the attention that I am
looking for so when men approach me they
don't approach me like I'm a hoe when a
man approach me they approach me with
respect ever everything comes down to
how you choose to portray yourself a lot
of women want to portray themselves as
hoes and be like yeah I'm that girl hot
girl summer what do you think that's
going to do to you what is that going to
do to your other sisters handle yourself
with more care I stand here like I said
I want to be a role model to every
single woman be powerful be strong be
intellectual be educated but don't
forget respect yourself don't be saying
that [ __ ] who I want to [ __ ] no be
selective I agree women definitely need
to be held accountable definitely
because I do think like Tate said we are
the ones creating the problems for each
other because if you're opening your
legs to any man now then they don't even
feel the need to get married anymore
because they're like well I can just get
sex like it's so easy however that what
I'm just trying to say is don't we can't
just put it on the women because these
men are the one sleeping with them for
50 for 50 years we have put it on the
man okay there's a lot of little things
in society you guys probably don't even
notice and I didn't either before I
started like really listening to what
men say like if you say okay she got
knocked up it sounds like something that
happened to her not a choice she made
who knocked her up he did we always put
the blame on the men it's it's very new
this is a new type of content where you
put any accountability on women watch
watch some early 2000s like Steve Harvey
dating it no watch watch them early
2000s Steve Harvey dating advice where
these women come up to him and like he
just says oh like even even the idea of
oh you intimidate guys no there's
probably something about you that guys
don't like
and and that's just being honest
um sweet feminine girls don't intimidate
anybody there's probably something about
you guys don't like
um and then on top of that it's like
I just think men are never allowed to
have standards like even every time a
man has a standard he's shamed for it so
if they say oh I like thin women I like
pure women they say he's slut-shaming
body shaming it's not the same for for
for women as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible